we're going to begin in Memphis
Tennessee today where a man's death at
the hands of police is Raising concerns
there that there could be Nationwide
protests that's because body cam video
will be released later today showing the
very violent arrest Tyree Nichols family
says the footage shows him being beaten
relentlessly after a traffic stop he
died just days later and now five former
officers have been charged with
second-degree murder we are told that
this video is extremely disturbing I
know you've heard that too so much so
that police departments across the
country are on alert for possible unrest
Lise Preston has been following the
story in Memphis and joins us now with
the latest Elise good morning to you
good morning to you Gail four of those
former officers have posted bail the
Shelby County district attorney says the
video will be released after 6 PM when
school is out and the business day is
over local leaders are calling for
peaceful protest
we all want the same thing we want
Justice
for Tyree Nichols investigators describe
the video of Memphis police beating 29
year old Tyree Nichols as appalling
wrong and criminal I've been policing
for more than 30 years
I've devoted my life to this profession
and I'm grieved
frankly I'm shocked
I'm sickened by what I saw the five
officers involved in nichols's arrest
were fired and now faced several charges
including second-degree murder
aggravated assaults and official
misconduct
police say Nichols was pulled over for
alleged reckless driving and an
altercation occurred after he tried to
run away Nichols family says he was
restrained beaten tased and pepper
sprayed by several officers While others
stood by and did nothing this photo was
taken out the hospital afterward the
actions of all of them resulted in the
death of Tyree Nichols and they are all
responsible lawyers for two of the
former officers said their clients will
plead not guilty but neither attorney
had watched the body camera footage no
one out there that night intended
for Terry Nichols to die this incident
was heinous Reckless and inhumane the
city's police chief said the officers
failed the community and pushed for
peaceful protests when the body camera
video is released I expect you to feel
outraged in the disregard of basic human
rights
[Applause]
call for civility
the little light vigil and her son's
honor at Escape Park Thursday friends
say Nichols who love skateboarding was
at his happy as there when that tape
comes out tomorrow
it's gonna be horrific
but I want each and every one of you to
protest in peace
I don't want us burning up our cities
tearing up the streets because that's
not what my son stood for
now President Biden released a statement
also calling for peaceful protests
meanwhile the Memphis Shelby County
School District the largest school
district here in the state has canceled
all after school activities and
anticipation of today's release Gail
Elise thank you